ce grand bâtiment neuf et le cadre de
vie de près de 70 personnes en situation
de handicap intellectuel et parfois
physique et ce jour là c'est un jour de
visite pour ses pensionnaires
il rencontre la présidente du conseil
départemental c'est un moment
particulier on a essayé de leur
expliquer vont ils ont diverses
pathologies donc ils sont pas tous en
capacité de comprendre c'est vrai qu'on
leur a expliqué que madame dindar venait
aujourd'hui que c'était la présidente et
que c'est elle aussi qui avait financé
en partie dont établissements pour eux
passés vraiment c'est vraiment un moment
de plaisir c'est un moment de détente et
celle constatée
la majorité sont tous heureux ils ont
tous envie de prendre une photo avec
elle dans le coin de la salle sébastien
attend son tour
déficient intellectuel mais aussi visuel
cette structure moderne est idéal pour
son double handicap
le but est que ça se passe très bien
pourquoi ça se passe bien il ya toujours
des ja des certaines personnes qui
m'aident beaucoup
horizon alors il y a
notamment il ya des éducateurs qui mène
est aussi bien des résidents des parfois
aussi
aussi des résidents une relation simple
s'instaure alors avec ses déficients
intellectuels qui n'ont pas leur langue
dans leur poche elle sans vrai parce que
même avec la présidente m à la viadène
télé mais est ce de ghana mène à moins
là où couper parce que nous aller
marcher mafate
comment wade à nous lancer voilà c'est
très important de discuter c'est du
direct
au fond c'est l'émotion menaçant
d'abaisser cette visite permet aux élus
d'appréhender l'utilisation des fonds
publics alloués à cette structure
en plus avec la tête
d'atelier en atelier le foyer d'accueil
occupationnel donne des cadre
d'épanouissement juste à côté
le foyer d'accueil médicalisé offre des
conditions de vie moderne à toutes ces
personnes handicapées voilà c'est très
important pour nous d'échanger parce
qu'on a déjà pas trop souvent cette
occasion et lorsqu'on là on est vraiment
sur le site en direct avec les problèmes
qui se posent ici et on peut les exposer
et la présidente comprend beaucoup mieux
ce qui se passe et comment on agit
comment on travaille comment on
accompagne les résidents qui sont chez
nous tout ce qu'ils peuvent faire elle
voit directement leurs réalisations et
peut-être l'appréhension de tout ce qui
touche
cet accompagnement il n'y a pas que
l'accueil en établissement il ya la
problématique du transport et à la
problématique du loisir la problématique
aussi du vieillissement des adultes
porteurs de handicap qui eux mêmes ont
des parents qui deviennent dépendants
avec la grande question de l'après une
fois que je serai plus là les angoisses
des parents chaque espace est ainsi
l'occasion des changes entre les
différents protagonistes à cet
accompagnement de quoi s'enrichir et
avancer c'est un bel échange et j'ai
presque aussi envie de dire d'une belle
formation pour nous les élus quand nous
venons prendre une journée en
établissement avec la visite la
rencontre les échanges professionnels
oui nous sommes nous mêmes nous nous
enrichissons humaine